So, let's see what is memory consistency
and how it differs from coherence. What coherence
does is define the order of accesses
observable by different threads, if these accesses go
to the same memory location or to the same address. Coherence is needed in order
to share data. Without coherence, a thread
is allowed to modify memory location while another
thread is allowed to read forever the old
value of that location, in which case we
can not really write shared memory programs that
work. An important thing about coherence, however, is
that it defines the order of accesses to
the same address. It does not say anything
about accesses that go to different location. And
that is what memory consistency is about. It defines
the order of accesses to different addresses. So, the
big question now, before we get into consistencies, does this
even matter? If we guarantee that when I write
to something, all the other cores get to see it,
and that happens for every address. As in, I
write to A, somebody sees what I wrote. I write
to B, somebody sees what I wrote. What can
change about the order of accesses to different addresses and
how does that even matter if I need to maintain this?